[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour votre grand
rendez-vous parlementaire hebdomadaire
cette semaine bien sûr et bien les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement al
commence dans quinze minutes exactement
à 15 heures au menu plusieurs questions
notamment autour des manifestations
contre le racisme et la question des
violences policières mais aussi encore
des questions sur les conséquences du
coc vide à mes côtés est la sénatrice l
air de l'essonne laure darcos bonjour
merci de répondre à mes questions vous
étiez hier aux déplacements d'edouard
philippe dans l'essonne à la rencontre
des policiers au lendemain de ces
annonces pour améliorer la déontologie
de la police
y at il pour vous un problème de
déontologie à un problème de violence de
racisme dans la police aujourd'hui
tout d'abord je voulais dire qu'on
n'était pas au déplacement puisque
bizarrement avec l'état d'urgence lé
tous les parlementaires n'étaient pas
conviés mais on a eu un petit déjeuner
républicain très intéressant très
enrichissant avec le premier ministre et
je viens de normandie
très tôt il ya matin la préfecture c'est
symboliquement très important qui
viennent chez nous parce que j'ai pas si
vous vous rappelez mais il ya eu aussi
des agressions de policiers
oui réguliers notamment se souvient de
viry châtillon en 2018 et l'a
dernièrement un caillassage pendant
confinement d'un mère alice donc pour
nous c'était important qu'il ya eu des
violences à l'égard de la police
exactement si des messagers de la pas
alors là je sais bien mais c'est oui
c'est important aussi vous dire pour
ceux sur ce fait là parce que ce que le
premier ministre a rappelé c'est que
bien évidemment il fallait qu'on donnait
tout acte de racisme ou ou délit de
faciès l'a rappelé à plusieurs reprises
mais en même temps j'ai senti qu'il
voulait aussi alors je sais pas si c'est
par rapport à son mini de l'intérieur
mais montrer aussi la solidarité par
rapport à la police et c'est ça aussi
pour ça qu'il est allé voir aussi un
commissariat et ensuite visité une
association qui essaie de mettre du lien
entre la population et la police
pourquoi parce que c'est important de
montrer que au fond
ces derniers mois et il l'a rappelé
entre les gilet jaune les retraites
avait beaucoup de manifestations et le
confinement
les policiers ont été extrêmement sûre
temps d'une tonalité vous le dites
différente de celle de son ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner que
voulez vous dire par là christophe
castaner qui a notamment la veille
promis une tolérance zéro contre le
racisme dans la police
ça veut dire que ce n'était pas le cas
jusque là vous avez discours avait pour
nom de l'intérieur c'est pas ça c'est
que je trouve que il a été maladroit il
était dans son rôle mais évidemment de
dire sa tolérance zéro contre le racisme
et qui était une évidence normalement
bien sûr mais qui existe partout
je connais également politique enfin
médiatique pardonnez moi vous avez fait
un peu partie mais également
l'emballement politique en fait la
récupération politique est très
dangereuse parce que ça fait bien
évidemment le lit du front national
c'est donc pour vous il ya un problème
de récupération politique
certains parient oui oui parce que
évidemment ce qui s'est passé aux états
unis est absolument effroyable j'en ai
pas dormi la nuit en voyant la vidéo en
entier de la mort de ce départ c'était
juste épouvantable mais je pense qu'il
ne faut pas tout assimiler et en france
je ne pense pas qu'ils aient plus de
racisme dans la peau listes que dans le
reste de la population
il faut les condamner bien évidemment
preuve de racisme global parce que
manuel macron ce matin au conseil des
ministres a parlé d'une maladie qui
touche toute la société en parlant du
racisme en france
alors je vous dis je veux être choqués
mais ce qui m'a choqué dans certaines
manifestations dernièrement c'est que
bien évidemment il faut ne pas tolérer
les racismes mais il ya également un
racisme anti blanc qui peut finalement
aussi apparaître dans des zones de
non-droit dans des universités regarder
ces associations où on demande à ce qu'
il n'y ait pas de deux personnes
blanches dans
les rats sont le rassemblement je ne
suis pas qu'il fait extrêmement
polémique
je sais bien mais ce n'est pas je me
dédouane pas en disant ça je pense que
toute forme d'intolérance de racisme
doit être bien évidemment totalement
condamnée mais je vous dis de la
différence c'est que je pense que
castaner monsieur castaner à a donné ces
mesures pour lutter contre le racisme
mais il a oublié également remercié les
policiers et je pense que le premier
ministre en venant hier matin c'était
aussi pour ça qu'il le faisait un mot
pour conclure sur un tout autre sujet
laure darcos les violences conjugales le
sénat a adopté hier la proposition de
loi d'aurélien pradié en s'imposant au
décret polémique du 27 mai que certains
jugeaient contreproductif il donne à la
victime 24 heures maximum pour informer
son conjoint violent de la procédure
ouverte à son encontre
vous avez confiance dans l'exécutif pour
qu'au final est bien cette mesure ne se
retrouvent plus là écoutez en tout cas j
avais une belle unanimité hier soir avec
un avis favorable de la commission des
lois
sur ce sujet nous avions déjà essayé de
faire passer cet amendement lors de la
la proposition doit d'aurélien pradié en
décembre dernier c'était important pour
nous et ça n'est surtout pas aux
victimes en effet de payer en tout cas
cet avertissement et cette demande
ordonnance d'éloignement donc
symboliquement c'était très important
qu'on le fasse
surtout dans une période où le
confinement était très très difficile
pour les violences intra familiales et
conjugales il ya merci beaucoup leur
darcos d'avoir répondu à mes questions
je vais maintenant avoir le plaisir
d'accueillir le vice-président
socialiste du sénat sénateur de paris
david assouline
merci beaucoup de prendre place david
assouline merci laure darcos on va
parler ensemble et bien des
manifestations anti racistes vous étiez
présent hier à paris tout d'abord sur le
fait que certains se disent ces
manifestations eh bien elles ne sont pas
autorisées vous l'assumez certains
critiquent votre vote représente la
présence des hommes politiques hier
c'était une manifestation totalement
toléré par voilà le ministre de
l'intérieur
et d'ailleurs tous ceux qui étaient là
étaient très responsable tolérer
autorisée on est quand même de la part
de christophe castaner qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de ces propos là dessus
non je pense que voilà à partir du
moment où il ya des règles générales qui
n'ont pas encore été modifiées
c'était son rôle de dire les choses mais
il a clairement dit que c'était autorisé
ou dans le sens qu'on pouvait y
participent les dissimulations dé
preuves les règles juridiques bien sûr
mais il assure il ya des moments comme
cela alors bien entendu les
organisateurs dont ils ont tout de suite
d'ailleurs dit au micro qu'il fallait
respecter les distances les gestes
barrière il avait des milliers de
masques à disposition du gel et c'est
bon ce qui est preuve de grandes
responsabilités m'enfin le sujet était
oui quand il y à de tels faits et
notamment là il ya il s'agissait d'abord
de rendre hommage à georges le fleuve et
c'est c'était une émotion tout à fait
légitime qui s'est fait dans la dignité
c'était dans le monde entier et paris
est la place de la république devait
être au rendez vous c'est évident y at
il pour vous un problème de racisme dans
la police française
et puis deuxième question y at il un
prime de racisme plus globale en france
parce que emmanuel macron ce matin en
conseil des ministres a lui parlé d'une
maladie qui touche toute la société
bien entendu que le racisme on le voit
on le voit qu'ils touchent la société y
compris ceux
qui dans la sphère politique
l'alimentent font des scores tout à fait
important dans les élections
régulièrement je parle du rassemblement
national donc c'est évident qu'il ya
cette pression sur la société et donc
l'ensemble des corps sociaux sont
touchés mais justement la police garanti
la paix civile et la police républicaine
c'est celle qui protège nos libertés
notre a terni t et notre égalité
c'est à dire les valeurs de la
république et donc c'est
particulièrement nocifs
quand son sein on laisse propre et
prospérer le racisme et les violences
qui peuvent aller avec
donc c'est très important justement pour
la police elle-même et pour la
conscience qu'elle doit susciter dans la
jeunesse de ne avoir aucune complaisance
et aucun déni là dessus est-ce qu'il y
en a eu jusqu'ici de la complaisance du
déni par exemple lorsque christophe
castaner dit maintenant c'est tolérance
zéro sur le racisme dans la police c'est
à dire qu'il ya eu vraiment ce problème
pour vous bien sûr appartement où il dit
maintenant c'est tolérance zéro c'est
qu'avant c'etait pas tolérance zéro donc
ils avaient donc d'une certaine façon il
a fait un pas et d'ailleurs c'est le pas
essentiel qu'il faut avoir c'est arrêter
avec le déni ce ne sont pas des petits
faits marginaux qui ne compte pas c'est
important par exemple il ya quelque
chose qui n'est pas forcément meurtrier
mais qui est en dommages le pacte
républicain
c'est le quotidien des contrôles au
faciès et ça personne ne peut dire que
c'est marginal
moi et mes enfants qui ont entre 20 et
30 ans ils me disent depuis qu'ils sont
adolescents que quand ils se baladent
avec des amis sont contrôlés et pas et
pas eux
c'est à dire
il ya quand même donc une discrimination
d ivoire bien sûr et et vous pensez bien
que ça se vit de façon très douloureuse
dès la plus tendre jeunesse
et puis il ya tout le reste qui a été
révélée par la presse pourquoi c'est la
presse qui révèle qu'il ya ces sites
facebook qu'il y ait de tels propos
merci à la presse mais ça devrait être
mis au grand jour et pas étouffé et
paniers dans la police elle-même et
surtout par les responsables et par le
gouvernement eh bien merci beaucoup
david assouline d'avoir répondu à mes
questions je vais à présent accueillir
un philippe bas le président les
républicains de la commission des lois
merci beaucoup de répondre à mes
questions philippe bas bonjour d'abord
que pensez vous du fait que le
gouvernement crée sa propre commission
pour enquêter sur sa gestion du coc vide
ce sont des bonnes pratiques c'est un
retour d'expérience que cherche le
gouvernement clame t-il à ce qu'il a
raison si c'est un retour d'expérience
il est parfaitement libre effectivement
de se poser des questions sur sa propre
pratique en vue de l'améliorer si ça
porte ses canons ont cure de commission
denquête il va de soi que dans aucune
constitution démocratique au monde c'est
l'exécutif qui s'auto évaluer parce que
entre l'auto évaluation et
l'autoprotection il ya qu un pas qui
risquerait dans l'opinion publique
d'être vite franchi la constitution qu
est ce qu elle nous disait le conscient
que le rôle d'évaluation des politiques
publiques à partir non pas à ceux qui
conduisent les politiques publiques mais
au parlement et notamment au sénat libre
indépendant non alignés qui doit réunir
tous les éléments d'information qui
utilise tous les moyens prestation de
serment pouvoirs d'investigation sur
pièce sur place auditions auxquelles on
est obligé de répondre qui sont
publiques
ça c'est notre pratique de l'exercice
des pouvoirs du contrôle est
indépendante parce que l'on entende doit
maîtriser bien sûr notre commission elle
sera indépendante
est ce que ces sous-entendus que vous
votre commission alors à la commission
denquête 10 cl barlin politique
notre commission
autre connexion ma commission elle est
indépendante
c'est une drôle de phrases c'est une
autre alors on va voir s'il assume on va
parler également de ce projet de loi
présenté ce matin en conseil des
ministres pour l'après état d'urgence
qui va notamment permettre et bien
d'interdire pendant quatre mois certains
rassemblements certains accès aux
transports qui vont être réglementé
fermeture de certains lieux est ce que
tout ça pour vous c'est justifié c'est
quand même des atteintes aux libertés
publiques sur la longueur sur 4 mois
encore après l'état d'urgence bon faut
pas jouer sur les mots ou bien on
prolonge l'état d'urgence parce que la
situation sanitaire le justifie ou bien
on le prolonge pas on n'est pas dans un
entre-deux ni dans un en même temps en
réalité le gouvernement j'ai vu son
texte il est public depuis ce matin ils
renvoient expressément aux dispositions
de l'état d'urgence pour la liberté
d'aller et venir pour la fermetures
éventuelles d'établissements qui
reçoivent du public pour l'organisation
des transports collectifs pour
l'interdiction de certaines
manifestations
autrement dit nous dit alliance année
plus de l'état d'urgence moi je lui
réponds bah c'est quand même de l'état
d'urgence alors toute la question l'état
d'urgence la qui fêtera débat entre nous
ce sera d'assumer par leur nom les
choses
si l'on doit poursuivre l'état d'urgence
il faut que la situation sanitaire le
justifie et sinon on ne poursuit pas
l'état d'urgence mais on sait que on a
le droit de le remettre en place par un
simple décret du gouvernement du jour au
lendemain
donc nous allons travailler sur cette
question nous allons entendre les
informations scientifiques sur l'état de
l'épidémie et nous verrons bien à ce
moment là ce que nous déciderons mais en
tout cas nous prendrons une décision
frange pas dans un entre deux très
rapidement tout cela intervient alors
qu'il ya bien sûr les manifestations
anti raciste actuellement notamment la
sphère adama traoré qui a été bien
ressuscité par lafarge floyd aux états
unis l'âme garde des sceaux nicole
belloubet apte à lui pour vous raison de
contacter la famille d'adama de traoré
pour échanger avec elle elle elle assume
en tout cas
il faut pas faire ça ce sont des
justiciables qui ont qui sont en pleine
discussion avec la justice on ne doit
pas choisir quand on est garde des
sceaux entre les justiciables et ont de
nouveau pression dans ce mail et du
travail de la justice on doit garantir
son indépendance ça c'est le rôle du
garde des sceaux bien merci beaucoup
philippe bas d'avoir dit à mes questions
je vais à présent accueillir alors que
nous sommes à quelques minutes des
questions d'actualité loïc hervé
sénateur uc de la haute savoie
loïc hervé bonjour j'en parlais à
l'instant avec philippe bas on va sortir
de l'état d'urgence le 10 juillet mais
il ya un nouveau projet de loi qui
prépare la presse est ce que c'est le
retour de l'état d'urgence sur quatre
mois en tout cas philippe bas et estime
que c'est une forme d'état d'urgence qui
va y avoir encore parler d'abord la date
du 10 juillet c'est nous qui l'avons
fixé au sénat nous avons ramené cette
date au 10 juillet qui n'entrent en
juillet au 10 juin absolument et moi je
suis très heureux que cette date du 10
juillet soit confirmée c'est important
pour que nos compatriotes aient le
sentiment que nous sortons de cette
crise épidémique après que le
gouvernement prévoit des mesures de fin
de l'état d'urgence je comprends par
contre il est hors de question de
prolonger trop longtemps
des mesures qui s'apparente à l'état
d'urgence sur un plan juridique
comme sur un plan sanitaire évidemment
mais c'est une bonne nouvelle et je m'en
réjouis
est ce que vous craignez donc du coup
avec ce nouveau projet de loi présenté
ce matin une limitation de nos libertés
publiques sur quatre banques une
limitation qui peu à peu va envahir
notre droit commun déjà qu'elles sont
dans les habitudes de certains français
c'est pas le danger que je que je crains
le plus le évidemment la limitation des
libertés publiques a été considérable
avec le confinement et et vous savez que
se réfère stop commises par exemple
j'étais très mobilisée pour qu on soit
très vigilant et qu'on pose des jalons
des garanties c'est important des
difficultés qui ne sont toujours pas
levée mais ce que je ne veux pas c'est
qu'on fasse rentrer dans le droit commun
dans le droit habituel le droit qui est
celui de la vie ordinaire
des mesures qui sont celles de l'état
d'urgence est valable en matière de
lutte contre le terrorisme mais c'est
aussi en matière sanitaire
on le droit français doit être un droit
protecteur des libertés individuelles et
c'est quelque chose à laquelle le sénat
est très attaché à loïc hervé également
vous allez tout à l'heure vous exprimer
au nom de votre groupe sur le texte qui
prépare le second tour des municipales
un texte qui prévoit éventuellement
l'annulation du scrutin
on n'en est plus là il est très probable
que les élections municipales aient lieu
le 28 juin dans l'essentiel du
territoire national et donc nous avons
pas grand chose à faire avec ce texte
puisque il sera sans vie des deux
descentes est la substance par contre il
reste quand même la question des
élections des français de l'étranger les
élections consulaires
il ya six sénateurs dans douze en tout
mais si dans la série de 2020 qui sont
élus sur la base de ce corps électoral
aucun sujet et puis à la suède à xi'an
où l'épidémie n'est pas encore
totalement maîtrisé donc il faut il
faudra qu'on ait quand même des mesures
ou si un nouveau cluster apparaît nous
aurons besoin de évidemment d'y revenir
lake hervé parmi les sujets il ya aussi
le sujet du vote par procuration le
sujet du vote par correspondance
on voit sur le vote par procuration il
peut y avoir un accord avec l'exécutif
mais sur le vote par correspondance est
beaucoup plus compliquées alors sur le
vote par sur les procurations n'y a pas
de problème il faudrait qu'on monte à
deux procurations parlera pas par
électeur et sur le vote par
correspondance est beaucoup trop tard
pour mettre ça en place pour le 28 juin
eh bien merci beaucoup lake avait
d'abord répondu à mes questions tout de
suite on prend la direction de
l'hémicycle puisque la séance vient de
commencer gérard larcher est installé
tout de suite les questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement maintenant nous revenons un
format de 15 questions
d'autres séances se déroulent dans les
conditions naturellement de respect des
règles sanitaires
avec les mesures sanitaires de
désinfection chacun veillera à ré
respect des distances de sécurité les
sorties je le rappelle pour les
sénateurs devront s'effectuer par les
portes situées au plus retourner
mystique pour le gouvernement par le
devant notre séance et retransmise en
direct sur public sénat avec les
questeurs le 22 juin à nos referons un
point pour l'évolution du format dans
lequel nous siégeons nous venons
d'ailleurs d'échangés qui est président
de groupe
sur ce point il y à quelques minutes
la parole est à notre collègue madame la
présidente eliane assassi pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes elle a deux minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
bravant les distanciation physique des
marées humaines déferlent dans le monde
entier pour dire stop aux inégalités
raciales la morge de georges floyd
victimes de violences policières a fait
se lever avant planétaire pour dire que
lévis noir compte cette exigence trouve
un écho puissant en france avec
l'affairé adama traoré pour qui vérité
et justice sont exigées l'impunité doit
cesser
depuis longtemps les violences
policières sont une préoccupation dans
les quartiers populaires mais il a fallu
les répressions violentes des gilets
jaunes pour qu'elles soient partagées au
niveau national les traitements
discriminatoires existe au sein de la
police comme au sein de la société
à la nuance près quand même que les
policiers sont détenteurs de l'autorité
publique et de la violence légitime que
certains rendent illégitime
dois-je ici rappeler toutes ces affaires
sordides de violence policière sur fond
de racisme
certains ont été agressés théorie hier
gabriel aujourd'hui d'authie ont trouvé
la mort zyed et bouna à damas sans
compter
tous ont usé de devoir justifier leur
identité parfois plusieurs fois par jour
monsieur le premier ministre
quelles réponses structurelles comptez
vous apporter pour rompre définitivement
avec ces pratiques racistes et d'une
violence disproportionnée noter au sein
de la police on vous répondre la parole
est à monsieur le premier ministre
gordon avait la parole monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la présidente je réponds bien
volontiers à la question que vous posez
qui est une question qui est au fond au
coeur du pacte républicain
comment dans une société démocratique et
libre peut-on faire prévaloir l'ordre
public
comment dans une société démocratique
libre construit sur l'idée
d'universalité de l'universalité de
l'homme des femmes et des hommes
c'est-à-dire leur profonde égalité leur
profonde en droit à leur profond de
liberté
comment faire que cette part pour le
moins obscures et j'allais dire presque
éternel d'incompréhensions de peurs de
stigmatisation de ce qui est différent
de ce qui n'est pas identique
comment faire pour la contenir et dans
toute la mesure du possible pour la
faire disparaître
c'est pas une question simple madame la
présidente
et si si nous vivions dans un monde
idéal et qu'il suffisait de proscrire
d'interdire le racisme nous l'aurions
déjà fait et l'effet est déjà produite
par dans le loiret déjà produit ses
effets ça n'est pas le cas et donc la
question que vous posez et sensible j'ai
un désaccord avec vous je sais pas si
j'ai un désaccord avec vous madame la
présidente
mais en tout cas je ne crois pas et je
ne laisserai pas dire car ça ne
correspond pas à l'expérience que j'ai
que la police ou la gendarmerie serait
et c'est d'ailleurs parce que vous avez
dit madame la présidente
ça n'est pas ce que vous avez dit je le
dis parce que n'est pas impossible que
ma réponse
dépasse les murs de cette enceinte ce
n'est pas ce que vous avez dit je ne
peux pas laisser dire et je ne laisserai
jamais dire que la police ou la
gendarmerie serait d organisation des
institutions violentes ou raciste elles
ne sont je le dis madame la présidente
ni l'une ni l'autre ni l'une ni l'autre
la police et la gendarmerie sont des
institutions qui à la différence de
beaucoup d'autres sont extrêmement
contrôlée placé sous l'oeil vigilant des
médias de nos concitoyens des organismes
internes d'inspection et de contrôle la
police et la gendarmerie ou plus
exactement les policiers et les
gendarmes exerce des missions
redoutablement difficile vous le savez
vous le savez rester calme en toutes
circonstances appréhender les
malfaiteurs être exposés à un risque
permanent du simple fait que l'on est
dépositaire de l'autorité publique bien
souvent du simple fait que l'on porte un
uniforme et nous avons tous tous en tête
des exemples nombreux de femmes et
d'hommes quels qu'ils soient qui ont été
attaqué et pris pour cible parce qu'il
portait cet uniforme qui fait leur
fierté et qui est notre protection
vous avez évoqué cette période
particulière et au fond malheureuse dit
des gilet jaune et vous avez indiqué
madame la présidente que cette période
démontrerait à l'évidence des
prétendants démontrerait des violences
ou illustrerait pardon voilà vous avez
raison illustrerait des violences
policières
cette période a été violente
elle n'a pas été le fait de violences
choisi exercée par la police sur des
manifestants pacifiques
je vous le dis comme je le pense comme
je les ai vécus madame la présidente
nous avons assisté dans cette période je
ne mets pas tout le monde dans le même
panier bien entendu mais nous avons
assisté dans cette période à des mises
en cause à des insultes et des crachats
à des violences incroyablement intense à
l'égard des policiers et des gendarmes
l'exercice du métier de policier de
gendarme dans la société dans laquelle
nous vivons et nous pouvons regretter
que la société dans laquelle nous vivons
soit brutale et violente est difficile
et je veux dire madame la présidente la
confiance l'estiment le respect absolu
absolue que j'ai pour les femmes et les
hommes qui s'engagent pour protéger
leurs concitoyens
et c'est parce que j'ai cette estime
cette confiance ce respect que j'ai
cette exigence que vous partagez j'en
suis sûr
cette exigence d'exemplarité qui dit
qu'aucun acte raciste ne peut être
tolérée dans l'absolu est peut être
encore moins lorsqu'il est le fait de
quelqu'un qui est dépositaire de
l'autorité publique
cette exigence doit être mise en oeuvre
je ne veux pas je ne veux pas que le
débat intense et délicat de la formation
de l'explication des missions de la
police de la définition des techniques
les plus adaptées dans une société qui
devient de plus en plus violente
je ne veux pas que ce débat soit comme
confisqué par des prises de positions
théâtrale par des raccourcis ou des
amalgames que tous nous avons dénoncé et
que nous devons tous continuer à
dénoncer avec des situations qui se
déroulerait ailleurs je le dis comme je
le pense
nous devons être confiants nous devions
être respectueux nous devons être
exigeants vis-à-vis des femmes et des
hommes
qui font vivre la police nationale et la
gendarmerie
et c'est cette ligne qui est une ligne
d'équilibré qui est une ligne équilibre
que je veux tenir mais je ne veux pas
madame la présidente que la peur change
de camp
je ne veux pas que la présomption passe
de celui qui troublent l'ordre public à
celui qui le défend parce que si nous
acceptons cette facilité de l'esprit
sous le coup de l'émotion et l'émotion
est légitime et elle est grande elle est
partagée
mais si nous acceptons cette facilité
alors c'est un basculement de la
république qui intervient et je vais
vous dire mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le basculement de la
république
quand je vois cela je me dis qu'il n'est
pas si loin alors je vous propose madame
la présidente d'être ensemble exigeant
avec les femmes et les hommes qui
composent la police nationale et la
gendarmerie
et de ce point de vue là nous sommes
d'accord mais que nous leur disions
parce que ici au sénat on est aussi une
institution parce que le premier
ministre
il est chef du gouvernement que nous
leur disions aussi vigoureusement au
delà de cette exigence notre confiance
et notre respect madame la présidente
oui merci merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur le premier ni j'entends
bien vous ne voulez pas que ce débat
soit confisquée par des prises de
positions théâtrale comme vous l'avez
dit je peux partager mais monsieur le
premier ministre pour ce faire il faut
aussi entendre et écouter un certain
nombre de propositions qui sont émises
par d'autres que votre force politique
par exemple le ministre de l'intérieur a
annoncé la fin de la clé d'étranglement
très bien mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que le plaquage ventrale reste autorisée
comme d'ailleurs le visage de l bd cac
40 dont nous demandons l'interdiction
les contrôles d'identité doivent être
traçables ici il faut savoir parler de
ça et il faut savoir écouter les
propositions qui sont faites et
j'entends certainement j'entends souvent
dans les couloirs des parlementaires me
dire mais madame la présidente vous avez
raison mais vous comprenez le rapport de
force il est ainsi et ça ne pourrait pas
être compris par tout le monde
je suis désolé mon groupe a fait un
certain nombre
deux propositions sur l'interdiction des
halles bd 40 sur le contrôle dit les
contrôles d'identité abusifs sur la
réforme de l'igpn dont il serait temps
sur laquelle il serait temps de se
pencher sur le rétablissement de la
police de proximité ok je pense qu'il
serait effectivement temps que nous
ayons un débat serein et constructif
pour répondre à la fois aux besoins des
fortes pour que dans d'autres pays et
aux besoins de deux des populations dans
les quartiers particulièrement la parole
et à notre collègue david assouline pour
le groupe socialiste et républicain vous
avez la barbe
monsieur le premier ministre mes chers
collègues notre police et notre
gendarmerie républicaines doivent
garantir la paix civile et protéger nos
libertés notre égalité et notre
fraternité
c'est une immense et noble tâche
accomplie dans des conditions de travail
inacceptables et qui comporte des
risques
nous leur avons unanimement rendu
hommage et on pense encore à m merabet
et arnaud beltrame a ses héros et c'est
pour cela que c'est particulièrement
insupportable quand on leur sein
certains souvent protégés par le silence
véhicule le poison du racisme le
reconnaître sans le minimiser ne jamais
couvrir de tels propos ou actes les
punit reprend demain sont une condition
de la confiance à retrouver avec une
grande partie de la jeunesse
c'est un impératif pour la dignité de la
police elle même et pour notre
république
tout commence monsieur le premier
ministre
par arrêté avec le déni est un pas dans
ce sens a été fait par le ministre de
l'intérieur et par vous même encore tout
à l'heure et nous nous en félicitons
mais l' ambiguïté subsiste quand on
entend encore monsieur nunez parler à
nouveau de quelques cas isolés
nous craignons qu'une fois l'émotion
passée on en revienne à l'avant comme
souvent dans le passé
bien entendu je le répète pas de faux
débat en france la police comme
institution n'est pas raciste mais le
racisme les discriminations n'y sont pas
marginales et les victimes ne sont pas
des exceptions
comme par exemple le quotidien du
contrôle au faciès
que comptez vous faire pour encourager
la remontée de tous les faits
répréhensibles
pour contrecarrer la loi du silence et
faire passer la loi de la république
toujours pour valoriser dans les
formations et dans les carrières celles
et ceux qui brillent par leur respect
des valeurs républicaines et de la
dignité humaine et au contraire que
soient mis au ban ceux qui font
l'apologie de la violence ou la pratique
abusivement et qui font l'éloge de la
haine raciste antisémite et homophobe
pour vous répondre la parole et
commerciaux le ministre de l'intérieur
se cache tonnerre
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur assouline
il n'y a pas de loi du silence il n'y a
que la loi et la police gendarmerie
chaque jour chaque nuit au quotidien
s'engage pour protéger et pour servir la
loi ils le font avec honneur ils le font
avec dignité
ils le font avec un total sens de
l'engagement et je vous le dis et vous
l'avez rappelé il n'y a pas de violence
dans la police il n'y a pas de racisme
policiers mais il existe il existe des
femmes des hommes qui peuvent sauter et
nous devons sur ce sujet être
particulièrement exigeant et je le suis
et je le suis monsieur le sénateur parce
que depuis 20 mois
j'ai l'honneur d'être le premier
défenseur des flics de france
j'ai l'honneur d'être ce défenseur parce
que je sais leur engagement je sais leur
engagement quotidien permanent je sais
leur sens de l'éthique collectif et
c'est parce que je suis le premier
défenseur des flics de france que je
porte monsieur le sénateur cette
exigence d'exemplarité
parce que quand on porte l'uniforme on
porte une parcelle de la république et
canton porte cette parcelle de répliques
on se doit d'être exemplaire
on se doit d'agir dans les tic et c'est
pour cela que j'ai rappelé un certain
nombre de règles
lundi tout en réaffirmant mon engagement
à leurs côtés
j'ai rappelé des règles qui sont des
règles essentielles sur tous ces sujets
j'ai rappelé monsieur le sénateur les
règles qui doivent prévaloir lors des
contrôles d'identité j'ai rappelé
monsieur le sénateur l'exigence aussi
que nous devons mener pour combattre
tout acte de racisme et je les dis
chaque soupçon chaque fait dès lors
qu'une enquête établi qu'ils sont
avérées doit faire l'objet d'une
sanction administrative immédiate
l'année dernière 30 faits de racisme ont
été signalés à l'igpn et ont fait
l'objet d'une enquête judiciaire
huit ont été classées sans suite 22 ont
été transmis au procureur de la
république dans ce cadre là monsieur le
sénateur je souhaite que dorénavant dès
lors qu'il ya transmission aux
magistrats et qu'on a les éléments qui
caractérisent une enquête qui mérite
justement cela il y à une suspension
une suspension administrative qui est
une mesure de protection de l'ensemble
de la police et ces mesures mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs sont fait
justement pour protéger l'honneur de nos
policiers l'honneur de nogent dame et je
sais qu'ils ont pleinement engagés en
cela merci la parole est à notre
collègue colette mélot pour le groupe
les indépendants saignements supérieur à
l'heure où la crise sanitaire a entraîné
la fermeture de nombreuses frontières
dans le monde entier
la plupart des étudiants ont dû renoncer
à leur séjour à l'étranger
pourtant en ce mois de juin les
inscriptions sont en cours de
finalisation et l'avenir des échanges
internationaux restent incertains pour
les étudiants et leurs établissements
d'accueil de nombreuses écoles de
formation supérieure prévoit dans les
cursus un stage ou une année de césure à
l'étranger mais les étudiants français
font face à de nombreuses restrictions
sur les visas en particulier aux états
unis ou bien se voient proposer des
stages en visioconférence dans le cadre
du programme erasmus certains étudiants
ont dû écourter ou annulés pour 25% leur
séjour à linverse se pose la question de
l'attractivité de la france à l'égard
des étudiants internationaux pour
certaines grandes écoles telles
qu'acheter ou sciences po il représente
près de 50% des effectifs
or la france est passée de la quatrième
destination étudiante à la cinquième
derrière l'allemagne
le programme bienvenue en france qui
poursuit l'objectif ambitieux
d'accueillir 500 mille étudiants
étrangers en 2027 risque malheureusement
d'être mise à mal
de nombreux chantiers sont encore à
engager je pense aux conditions de
logement que la période de confinement a
mis en évidence nous ne pouvons laisser
se profiler une année blanche de la
mobilité
les échanges internationaux d'étudiants
sont un déterminant important pour notre
économie à la fois gage de dynamisme
intellectuel source d'innovation et de
richesse culturelle il s'agit donc
aujourd'hui de rassurer les candidats
internationaux
alors madame la ministre quel dispositif
comptez-vous mettre en place afin de
lever toutes les contraintes actuelles
pour pouvoir accueillir les étudiants
internationaux dans les meilleures
conditions pour vous répondre la parole
et au ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche et
l'innovation david albelda merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
sénatrices à monsieur le sénateur madame
la sénatrice mélo le vous avez raison la
préoccupation est mondiale et la
mobilité qu'il s'agisse de celles des
étudiants ou de l'ensemble des citoyens
du monde et est en ce moment évidemment
empêché à cause de la pandémie cognon
vision néanmoins les écoles les
établissements se sont mobilisés pour
pouvoir proposer à la rentrée un certain
nombre de dispositifs qui pourront
maintenir la capacité à s'inscrire et la
capacité à se déplacer partout dans le
monde dès que ce sera possible
j'en veux pour preuve l'organisation au
travers des unités européennes des
universités européennes à l'intérieur de
l'espace schengen qui vont permettre de
maintenir des échanges dès que les
conditions sanitaires permettront à
nouveau les mobilités j'en veux pour
preuve aussi l'engagement des
partenariats internationaux des
universités et des écoles de manière à
pouvoir déployer les formations à
distance avec le premier ministre nous
avons décidé d'ouvrir un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt pour soutenir la
production de formation à distance de
manière à ce que les enseignements
puisse commencer partout dans le monde
et être dispensés par nos établissements
partout dans le monde
le temps que les trajets physique puisse
se remettre en place
c'est aussi évidemment un travail avec
les postes avec le ministère de l'europe
des affaires étrangères l'ouverture de
lieux d'accueil pour les étudiants qui
n'ont pas tous ses moyens de se
connecter dans les lieux où ils habitent
de manière à ce que nous puissions
préserver l'attractivité de la france et
des formations françaises auprès des
étudiants internationaux le plan
bienvenue en france nous a déjà permis
l'an dernier d'augmenter de 4 % le
nombre d'étudiants internationaux que
nous avons accueillis sur l'année 2019
2020 et bien sûr l'ensemble des
établissements et aux ministères sont
mobilisés pour que nous puissions
progresser encore et gagner notre place
je vous remercie merci madame idole
quelques secondes ont joué huit secondes
pour merci madame la ministre
et dire qu'il faut un élan pour la
mobilité de la jeunesse c'est
indispensable
la parole est maintenant président bruno
retailleau pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre il ya quelques semaines
je vous ai entendu parler d'écroulement
et ce terme mois ne m'avait pas choquer
vous parlait alors d'un écroulement
économique et social aujourd'hui la
menace qui est devant nous c'est celle
d'un écroulement civique
comment quelques jours avez vous pu
laisser l'état autant reculer des
manifestations interdites autorisé mais
surtout surtout des minorités agissantes
qui sous prétexte de l'antiracisme
veulent propager la haine vis-à-vis de
nos forces de l'ordre veulent fracturé
notre modèle républicain
quand une garde des sceaux s'immisce
dans une affaire privée privée alors que
elle doit être le garant de
l'indépendance de la justice
c'est évidemment l'état de droit qui est
fragilisée quand en retour de cette
invitation imprudente
elle reçoit un camouflé calculer c'est
toute la république est humilié quand
votre ministre de l'intérieur déclare
que l'émotion doit dépasser la règle de
droit
c'est ici mes chers collègues que nous
votons la loi c'est évidemment là aussi
une fragilisation de l'état de droit
c'est la porte ouverte à la loi de la
jungle et c'est aussi la possibilité
compromise demain de la concorde civile
et quand le même ministre fait cette
trouvaille cette acrobatie sémantique de
préjugés a viré qui va livrer nos
policiers et nos gendarmes à la
présomption de culpabilité
c'est évidemment la présomption
d'innocence qui est défigurée alors oui
nous devons être intraitables avec et
contre le racisme
vous avez raison mais sans tomber dans
les pièges les pièges de ce qui nous
tant qu'ils veulent communautariser la
france qu'ils veulent désigner notre
pays comme éternellement coupable
monsieur le premier ministre
les policiers les gendarmes sont notre
bouclier vous ne pouvez pas nous dire
ici avec des proclamations de respect et
estime qu' ils sont effectivement pour
nous une protection
vous devez leur prouver reprenez vous à
votre compte l'expression du ministre
l'intérieur
reprenez vous à votre compte
l'initiative de votre garde des sceaux
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs le
président je connais votre maîtrise du
langage
et d'ailleurs elle est souvent admiré
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
sachant précis je suis surpris par un
certain nombre d expression que vous
avez utilisé dans votre question et que
j'ai essayé de noter pour ne pas pour ne
pas vous exposer à la même critique que
celle que je pourrais éventuellement
formulée vous avez dit monsieur le
président retailleau que la garde des
sceaux avait voulu s'immiscer dans une
affaire privée
il n'en est rien monsieur le président
retailleau le fait que le ministre de la
justice propose de recevoir
vous allez me dire que non pas la
famille mais le comité qui s'est
constituée que je ne connais pas le fait
qu'ils existent pour avoir un échange
sur où nous en sommes sur des faits qui
sont anciens vous le savez sur une
instruction et qui est lente vous le
déplorez comme moi comme moi ne
constitue pas une immixtion dans la
procédure
en aucune façon en aucune façon il est
vrai que si à l'invitation d'un membre
de la famille
la garde des sceaux donné une
instruction individuelle alors nous
serions dans quelque chose qui n'est pas
légal et il ne vous a pas échappé que la
garde des sceaux avait à juste titre
indiqué qu'il n'en était pas question qu
il ne saurait en être question
je crois donc une surprise de taille aux
que en vous plaçant sur ce terrain vous
[Musique]
vous ne décrivait pas réellement la
position de la garde des sceaux son
expression et la volonté qu'elle a
affirmé de la même façon vous fait le
reproche au ministre de l'intérieur de
ce que en évoquant dans une interview le
concept dont je reconnais volontiers
qu'ils peuvent avoir la forme d'un
oxymore de soupçons avérés dans une
interview on répond on se placerait en
dehors des règles de la république
mais monsieur le président retailleau si
vous pensez vraiment cela alors je
crains et je sais que ce n'est pas vrai
que vous ignoriez la pratique
administrative actuelle car que se
passe-t-il monsieur le président
retailleau quand des faits qui n'ont pas
donné lieu à une déclaration de
culpabilité sont susceptibles de
troubler l'exercice du service public
l'autorité administrative peut et
souvent doit prendre des mesures avant
la déclaration de culpabilité des
mesures de suspension par exemple ça
n'est en rien une méconnaissance de la
présomption d'innocence que vous semblez
déploré cette de bonne administration
ce n'est pas moi qui les ai inventées et
ça n'est pas de ministre de l'intérieur
qu'il inventait c'est la pratique
constante constante monsieur le
président retailleau dans
l'administration et c'est une bonne
pratique et je l'assumé car lorsque des
faits
encore une fois sans que la justice
n'ait pu déterminer si les auteurs
présumés sont coupables lorsque des
faits sont de nature à créer une telle
impossibilité d'exercer sereinement le
service public alors l'autorité
administrative est dans son droit
lorsqu'elle suspend les agents c'est ça
qu'a voulu dire le ministre de
l'intérieur il a parfaitement bien fait
et puisque vous et moi nous sommes
attachés à la république puisque vous et
moi nous sommes attachés à la république
je préférerais que vous comme moi nous
expliquions cela parce que ça n'est pas
simple c'est vrai mais que nous
expliquions cela à nos concitoyens
qu'ils le comprennent parfaitement
plutôt que de feindre un autre sens à ce
qui a été dit
voilà ce que je vais vous dire monsieur
le président la parole maintenant notre
collègue de nice ap aussi l'union
centriste merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
secrétaire d'état aux transports
monsieur le ministre
alors que la crise économique succès de
la crise sanitaire les tables répondre
présent en soutenant les entreprises
à ce titre je salue le prêt de 7
milliards d'euros accordés air france
cette aide est significative mais aussi
nécessaire afin que l'entreprise puisse
affronter les difficultés financières du
secteur tout en répondant à ces enjeux
environnementaux
plus que jamais incontournable mais air
france ne doit pas oublier que ce
secours lui est apportée par ce que
l'entreprise répond à une obligation de
service public
anne offrant une desserte entre la
capitale et les territoires ruraux ou
ultra marins or dans ces départements
je constate que la participation à
l'aménagement du territoire
attendu n'est pas au rendez vous il
n'est pas normal par exemple qu'au mois
de juin les pyrénées atlantiques ne
bénéficie que de deux vols quotidiens
biarritz paris ou pire encore pire
encore de deux vols hebdomadaires pour
po paris voyage qui requiert autrement
schenker de train je regrette donc que
malgré les sollicitations répétées des
parlementaires air france n'est pas
augmenter la cadence des vols desservant
ces territoires enclavés ou éloignées
ceux ci ont pourtant cruellement besoin
de liaisons aériennes plus fréquentes
dans le cadre de la reprise économique
en effet comme l'a clairement établi la
mission d'information du sénat sur le
rôle du transport aérien dans
l'aménagement du territoire certaines
lignes sont vitales pour assurer le
désenclavement
monsieur le ministre je ne peux pas
croire que l'état tolère cette situation
aussi pouvez vous me dire comment ils
comptent h
en tant qu actionnaire d'air france et
après l'effort consenti pour sauver
cette entreprise pour l'amener à
desservir dignement ces territoires
qu'elles semblent délaissées je vous
remercie on vous répondra par les deux
secrétaires d'état en charge des
transports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
merci pour vos questions qui me permet
de revenir sur la reprise du transport
aérien durant le confinement vous savez
les restrictions prises dans le cadre de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire ont impliqué
une réduction de 95 % des vols et la
reprise du trafic intérieur reprend
progressivement aux organismes
progressivement plutôt depuis le 2 juin
grâce notamment à la levée de la
restriction de la règle des 100 km la
majorité des aéroports réouvriront aux
vols commerciaux d'ici à l'été à date
l'offre s'établit à environ 20% du
trafic habituel avec une augmentation
progressive 35 % en juillet environ 40%
en août grâce notamment à la réouverture
de l'aéroport de paris-orly prévue pour
le 28 le 26 juin prochain
nous avons bien évidemment une attention
particulière sur les lignes
d'aménagement du territoire mais j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir un peu plus tard
de nos débats concernant plus
spécifiquement la situation de pau je
tiens d'abord à vous rappeler qu'il
s'agit là d'une ligne commerciale et non
pas du nine soubie a obligation de
service public et plusieurs compagnies
opèrent des vols depuis cet aéroport en
fonction de la demande
air france vous l'avez dit qui a prévu
de reprendre avec deux vols par semaine
d'ici à fin juin puis 200 vols sur le
mois de juillet à destination de paris à
la fois orly et roissy et asl airlines
qui a quant à elle annoncé la mise en
place de quatre liaisons hebdomadaires
vers paris concernant la france vous
savez que la compagnie est actuellement
en train de préparer un plan de
restructuration de l'offre l'offre
commerciale et le gouvernement survit
gillot a que ce plan ne se fasse pas au
détriment des territoires
j'ai d'ailleurs demandé à la direction
d'air france d'entamer très rapidement
une concertation approfondie avec les
élus concernés
la parole est à notre collègue bernard
vie pour le groupe de la république en
mars le veut la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre
la cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
madame la ministre la crise sanitaire
que nous traversons a et aura un impact
évident sur les ressources et les
dépenses des collectivités locales
notamment sur les investissements celle
ci ce que souligne regrette déjà le
monde économique de nos territoires
c'est pourquoi il est indispensable
d'accompagner et de soutenir les
investissements des collectivités
territoriales qui représente
rappelons le 70% de l'investissement
public civil le gouvernement et vous
même madame la ministre qui connaissait
particulièrement bien les contraintes
des petites communes avaient entendu cet
appel à l'ensemble des mesures d'urgence
en direction des collectivités
territoriales le troisième projet de loi
de finances rectificative de l'année
présenté ce matin précise ce soutien
inédit de l'état vis-à-vis des
mécanismes et des garanties à ce titre
nous saluons le renforcement de
l'enveloppé de la dotation de soutien à
l'investissement local d'un milliard
d'euros si utile pour financement des
projets des petites communes par
ailleurs une circulaire a été adressée
au préfet il y a un mois pour proposer
des souplesses dans l'utilisation des
crédits d'investissement déjà mobilisés
madame la ministre compte tenu de
l'ampleur de la crise économique qui
touche les collectivités ces mesures
appel à des précisions sur la façon dont
gouvernement entend encourager et
soutenir les investissements des
collectivités sur les projets
d'investissements en cours
comment les reliquats de crédit pourront
ils être réalloués sur d'autres projets
et comment pourront être réaffectés les
attributions de subventions
plus encore les collectivités
territoriales se demandent quelle sera
l'engagement du gouvernement sur la
durée pourront-elles compter sur ce
soutien non seulement pour 2020 mais
aussi pour 2021 qui sera n'en doutons
pas très difficile également compte tenu
de la structure des recettes pour
certaines collectivités
merci madame la ministre tous ces
réponses qui sont attendus je le sais
par les élus qui doivent gérer un
exécutif local
on vous répond la parole quand madame la
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
des relations avec les collectivités
avaient la parole
merci monsieur le sénateur comme vous le
rappelez vous même les collectivités
territoriales porte la majeure part
si de l'investissement public et
constitue donc un partenaire très
important pour les entreprises puisque
leur investissement est un levier pour
le développement des entreprises et
notamment dans le bâtiment et les
travaux publics nous le savons tous la
réussite de la relance de l'économie
comme vous le dites vous-même passera
donc aussi par les collectivités
territoriales et il est donc très
important que les collectivités
territoriales et les moyens d'investir
c'est pourquoi le premier ministre a
lancé il y a dix jours que la dotation
de soutien à l'investissement local la
fameuse death il serait abondé d'un
milliard d'euros dès 2020 et s'est donc
inscrit dans le plf r3 par ailleurs je
vous rappelle qu'il y à déjà 2 millions
d'euros d' inscrit dans le plf pour
cette année entre la detr et la d6
l'existence mais j'insiste sur le
calendrier
nous avons voulu l'inscrire dans le plfr
3 pour que les équipes qui viennent
d'être mises en place ou qui vont se
mettre en place
après le 28 juin et les moyens d'agir et
savent qu'ils ont des moyens de pouvoir
investir
bien entendu je vous précise que les
crédits qui n'auront pas pu être engagés
en 2020 pourront être exceptionnellement
reportée sur 2021
vous m'interrogez également sur la
possibilité de réallouer des reliquats
de crédit utilisé sur d'autres projets
en effet j'ai donné instruction aux
préfets de veiller à ce que il y ait des
souplesse dans la gestion cette année de
la dtr puisqu'on sait que par exemple
certains dossiers ont été arrêtés ou
même stopper provisoirement et donc il
faut que une commune qui aurait
bénéficié de deux ter ont fait briller
pour un préjugé qui finalement ne
verrait pas le jour et bien puisse être
déplacée sur un autre projet et que la
subvention demeure dans la commune c'est
une souplesse dans l'exécution bien sûr
des crédits qui répond je crois aux
besoins des élus à la suite de la crise
duco vide enfin vous avez dit que vous
espériez que ça s'arrête pas là bien sûr
nous aurons d'autres budgets notamment
le plf pour 2021 et nous continuerons
bien sûr à veiller accompagner les
collectivités territoriales merci la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
éric jean ça mais tu as pour le groupe
il rassemble le vent démocratique et
social européen avait la parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur premier
ministre comme et dames mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ont cher bernard ma question
s'inscrit un peu dans la continuité et
elle s'adresse au ministre madame la
ministre la cohésion des territoires et
des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
les collectivités territoriales ont été
tout le monde l'a constaté sur
l'ensemble de ses ventes première ligne
également pour réagir face à la pandémie
qui nous a frappés qui nous frappe
encore elles se sont d'un côté vu
amputer d'une grande partie de leurs
recettes tout en engageant des dépenses
exceptionnelles liées à la gestion de la
crise ce matin était donc présenté au
conseil des ministres le troisième
projet de loi de finances rectificatif
dans lequel figurent des mesures
d'urgence pour les collectivités et la
mission qui a été menée par notre
collègue de l'assemblée jean rené
cazeneuve a estimé à environ 7 5
milliards d'euros les pertes de recettes
des collectivités répartis pour les
communes à 3,2 milliards 3,4 milliards
pour les départements et 09 milliards
pour les régions
vous nous proposer des outils
intéressants pour aider les
collectivités et clause de sauvegarde
que nous espérons conforme aux principes
de péréquation soutien aux trésoreries
mais il me semble qu'on peut
s'interroger sur le montant des aides
proposées pour les communes les aides
financières s'élèvent si je comprends
bien 1,75 milliard d'euros alors que
l'estimation des pertes retenu par le
gouvernement est de 3,2 milliards
l'association des maires de france
considère pour sa part que les pertes et
les dépenses engagées s'élèverait à 5
milliards donc 2,1 dont 2,2 milliards de
recettes tarifaires c'est à dire les
revenus liés à la restauration scolaire
les transports les crèches les piscines
celles ci seront tels compensés par
l'état pour ce qui est des départements
une aide plus conséquente est annoncée
2,7 milliards d'euros
celle ci permettra t-elle de compenser
intégralement les dépenses sociales
engagées pendant la crise
et enfin aucune annonce n'a été faite
pour les régions au grand mécontentement
des présidents qui estimait dans une
tribune du monde du 28 à 1,7 milliard
d'euros les dépenses exceptionnelles
engagées et appelé l'état à leur donner
des garanties afin de renforcer leur
responsabilité madame la ministre
j'ai bien conscience que plusieurs
questions figurent dans ma question mais
je peux la résumer de la manière
suivante quels critères avez vous retenu
pour arbitrer la répartition des moyens
entre les différents blocs et pouvez
vous garantir que l'aide de l'etat sera
suffisante pour aucune collectivité ne
soit laissé en difficulté mais ressent
vous répondre la parole de la milice de
la cohésion des territoires des
relations et des collectivités avaient
la parole merci monsieur le sénateur je
vais vous répondre précisément
effectivement il a été décidé on pèle
fr3 après un travail important fait par
jean rené cazeneuve de d'abord
s'agissant des communes et des
intercommunalités de bénéficier en 2020
d'une clause de sauvegarde sur leurs
recettes fiscales et domanial
intégralement financée par l'état le
père et 9 est retenu est large
il s'agit de l'intégralité des recettes
fiscales de toutes les redevances du thé
et de toutes les redevances
d'utilisation du domaine
pour vous donner un exemple concret
comment ça va se passer en 2020 ce il
recède une commune sont inférieurs à la
moyenne des trois derniers exercices
2017 2018 2019 l'état versera une
dotation permettant de garantir ce
niveau aucun critère aucune démarche ne
viendra limiter l'activité l'activation
de ce filet de solidarité c'est-à-dire
qu'il n'y a aucune contrainte par
rapport à la richesse et c'est toutes
les communes qui seront dans cette
situation pourront en bénéficier et
c'est un milliard 7,2 cours concernant
les départements
c'est une avance de trésorerie qui est
fait pour en ville
environ deux milliards sept comme
l'avait demandé l'adf notamment à cause
de la baisse des ddm t au
en parallèle nous engageons aussi d
discussion avec les départements
notamment dans le cadre des politiques
sociales qui vont être développés c'est
olivier ferrand qui a des projets de loi
sur grand âge et autonomie et bien sûr
nous discuterons bien sûr politiques
sociales et financement sur les régions
le calendrier est un peu différent car
la loi prévoit déjà des mécanismes de
garantie sur les recettes 2020 qui
conduiront à l'état à compenser environ
500 millions aux régions en particulier
en ce qui concerne la baisse de la tva
mais bien sûr je voulais vous dire que
nous discutons avec la région et j'ai un
dialogue avec les régions gérées latéral
avec tous les présidents de région pour
parler financement est aussi contrat de
plan état région et nous avons des
dialogues très constructif
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
à la houppe ère pour le groupe est
républicain vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
madame la secrétaire d'état le 27 mai
dernier soit une semaine après la
publication par zélande 7 d'une étude
sur les usages de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine votre ministère a interdit
l'usagé en a interdit l'usagé dans le
traitement du coc u19 cette interdiction
faisait suite au degré du 25 mars qui
défend des aux patients au libre aux
médecins libéraux de prescrire cette
molécule à leurs patients on sait ce
qu'il est advenu de cette étude qui a
été désavoué d'abord par les éditeurs du
27 et ensuite par trois de ces quatre
auteurs cette étude était en réalité une
vaste farce dont les scientifiques et
soignant les patients et votre
gouvernement en ont été les dindons
c'est triste on me rétorquera que
d'autres études n'ont pas pu démontrer
cette efficace et de l'efficacité de
cette molécule
mais la vérité est que les protocoles
mis en concurrence sont tellement
divergent qu'il est impossible
d'affirmer aujourd'hui que cette mode
véhicule est efficace ou pas même s'il
semble que les patients traités dès lors
dépistage et dont l'état ne nécessite
pas une hospitalisation s'en sortent
majoritairement mieux une chose est
absolument certaine en revanche
seuls les médecins sont afd a proscrit à
prescrire le protocole qui leur semble
le mieux convenir à leurs patients votre
gouvernement a peut-être un goût certain
pour les ordonnances
moi je préfère celle qui porte un
caducée ma question est simple dames le
secrétaire d'état netease ne serait-il
pas temps de reconnaître qu'il y a eu de
l'emballement dans cette affaire est de
redonner aux médecins la liberté de
prescrire merci pour vous répondre la
parole et que madame la secrétaire
d'état produisez solidarité de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur ou perd la mise en avant des
mécanismes d'action de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine a légitimement soulevé
beaucoup d'espoir ces dernières semaines
et ce au plus fort de la période
épidémique que nous venons de vivre de
nombreux des travaux de recherche vous
l'avez vous en avez cité quelques-uns
ont été menées pour tenter d'analyser
son efficacité et son innocuité dans le
traitement de la maladie kovy de 19
le ministre et l'ensemble du
gouvernement ont été transparents
tous les efforts ont été mis en place
afin de trouver des réponses rigoureuses
et scientifique à ces questions à ce jeu
à ce jour les travaux de recherche menés
n'ont pas réussi à démontrer avec un
niveau de preuve suffisants
l'efficacité de l'hydre optique le recul
chez les malades hospitalisés ou dans
les formes les plus simples par ailleurs
de nombreuses études ont montré montré
des effets secondaires connus et
renforcé dans certaines associations
médicamenteuses de travaux scientifiques
issus d'auteur similaires ont dû être
retirés en raison de questions sur
l'intégrité scientifique de ces travaux
et nous le déplorons
néanmoins l'ensemble des études
rassemblées à ce jour sur la question de
lido de l'utilisation de l'hydro de
cycle rapide dans le traitement de la
maladie qu'ovide ne justifie pas son
utilisation en pratique courante
compte tenu de la décroissance
progressive de l'épidémie cette question
devient aujourd'hui moins urgente et
certaines études se poursuivent encore
actuellement
enfin concernant la liberté de
prescription cette liberté n'a jamais
été entravée je rappelle que la liberté
de presse
inscription n'a jamais été totale
l'ordre des médecins l'a encore rappelé
récemment l'article 8 du code de
déontologie médicale précise que le
médecin est libre de ses prescriptions
dans les limites fixées par la loi et
compte tenu des données acquises de la
science je vous remercie
merci la parole et mccord notre collègue
martial bourquin
pour le groupe socialiste qui
répliquaient par deux les mois chers
collègues g mais si on perd bénéficier
de plus de 20 secondes
pardonnez moi pour madame la secrétaire
d'état
je suis parlementaire mais je suis aussi
médecin et s'est levé s'est quelquefois
s'éloigner des certitudes et
s'interroger et il ya des chiffres
intercond incontestable quand tes
certitudes et ces chiffres sont ceux de
votre ministère alors qu'on hospitalise
les gens pour les mêmes raisons en
france le taux de décès chez les
personnes hospitalisées est de 3,1 pour
cent à marseille et de 17,2 pour cent au
niveau national voilà qui devrait à tout
le moins vous interrogez madame la
secrétaire d'état
mais si la parole cette fois ci est
vraiment un martial burqa pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
l'asim seul président ma question
s'adresse au ministère de l'économie et
des finances au ministre pour dire que
l'industrie française est en grave
difficulté l'entreprise luxfer
produisait des bouteilles d'oxygène
l'entreprise famars de la chloroquine
pts / j call des sons de montain pour
les intubations la sucrerie de toury en
eure-et-loir du sucre et de l'alcool
nécessaire au gel hydroalcoolique
mais il ya aussi l'entreprise peugeot
japy à valentigney qui a été brutalement
fermé hier
il ya aussi general electric general
electric qui vient de connaître
quarante mille heures de travail
délocalisée en chine
il y a des dizaines et des dizaines
d'entreprises qui sont au bord
du dépôt de bilan pas seulement pour le
pour cause du coc vide
pas seulement mais parfois ça peut même
être un prétexte
alors aujourd'hui ces entreprises sont
fermées menacée de fermeture et vous
semblez celui disent avoir peur de la
seule solution parfois la prise de
participation de l'état voire même la
nationalisation monsieur le ministre au
début de la crise sanitaire
nous avons découvert que la france
sixième puissance économique mondiale
était incapable de produire sur son
territoire des masques des combinaisons
de protection des tests biologiques du
gel hydroalcoolique des respirateurs des
médicaments jérôme fourquet disaient les
français sont tombés de haut de très
haut de trait aux seuls ministres ma
question est simple
à quand une véritable politique
industrielle pour la france il n'y a pas
de grandes nations s'il n'y a pas un
socle industriel puissant pour nous
répondre à la parole et à la secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
des finances madame pas dire une hache
et merci monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bourquin je vais d'abord saluer
justement la mobilisation d'industrie
pendant cette crise parce
qu'effectivement face à une difficulté
d'approvisionnement en respirateur en
masque en gel hydroalcoolique en un mois
en un mois et nous parlons même parfois
de surcapacité sur certains de ces
objets l'industrie est française a
prouvé qu'elle était capable de se
mobiliser et de répondre à l'appel et
donc c'est plutôt le signal d'une grande
vivacité et d'une grande capacité de
réaction et de développement économiques
la deuxième chose que je veux dire c'est
que je me réjouis
votre enthousiasme pour la politique
industrielle s'est pas d'enthousiasmé
que je partage je crois qu'effectivement
il n'y a pas de grandes économies sans
grande industrie et c'est pour cela que
ce gouvernement depuis trois ans il n'a
pas attendu la crise du coc vide 19
s'est mobilisée au service de
l'industrie pour construire une
politique industrielle une politique
industrielle dans le domaine de la santé
avec le conseil stratégique des
industries de santé pour arrêter des
années de départ de sites et la division
par deux de nos parts de marché au plan
international entre 2008 et 2018 et ça
ce sont les faits une politique
industrielle qui a créé l'emploi
industriel est alors qu'entre 2000 et
2016 ceux ci avaient été
systématiquement supprimés
année après année et une politique
industrielle qui fait qu'aujourd'hui les
investisseurs étrangers s'intéressent à
la france comme endroit pour investir
puisque nous sommes toujours la première
destination pour les projets industriels
soutenus par des partenaires étrangers
ce sont les résultats qui viennent
d'être publiés par le cabinet 1 c'est
niang donc sur ces bases là nous devons
continuer sa politique continuer cette
politique c'est la politique de
relocalisation qui est en lien avec le
plan automobile 1 milliard d'euros
d'investissements au service de la
relocalisation de la chaîne de traction
électrique de la batterie électrique une
politique industrielle le service de
l'aéronautique nous venons de l'annoncé
hier une politique industrielle au
service de la santé et nous aurons de
beaux projets à vous présenter dans les
prochains jours quelques secondes
merci aux paysans madame la ministre
madame la ministre
la chine ne peut pas être l' usine du
monde il faut que nous ayons une volonté
de produire dans notre pays et à force
de tout expliquer à force d'avoir
accepté les délocalisations on s'est
aperçu durant cette crise très difficile
que la france pouvait devenir une nation
de seconde zone
et ça il n'y a rien de pire il est temps
de réagir
et faisons en sorte qu'avec les
collectivités locales nous ayons avec le
chili à chaque fois qu'une entreprise
est en difficulté on veille à ce qu'elle
reste sur notre territoire nous avons
besoin d'emplois industriels
nous avons besoin d'emplois tout court
nous avons besoin d'une france
industrielle une france de producteurs
pas seulement de consommateurs
bénéficiant d'un temps je voudrais
saluer martial bourquin qui va quitter
le cheddar pour rejoindre sa copine
d'eau dacourt qui a bien de la chance de
le retrouver
faudrait saluer son engagement pour le
cédant et notamment sa persévérance sur
les questions industrielles ou d'emploi
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à peu près collègues
claudine thomas pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame frédéric vidal
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur de
la recherche et de l'innovation
madame la ministre cette année six cent
cinquante-huit mille lycéens attendaient
le verdict de parcours sup
dès leurs premières résultats connus les
plaintes se sont multipliés
rappelant les nombreux ratés qu'avait
déjà connu ce dispositif l'année
dernière les améliorations promises par
votre ministère ne sont manifestement
pas au rendez vous pour tenter
d'accepter ce qui apparaît comme
arbitraire il faudrait au moins avoir
des éléments pour comprendre les
critères de sélection mais rien n'est
plus opaque que la façon dont
l'interface prend ses décisions
de nombreux lycéens malgré un très bon
dossier se retrouve aujourd'hui sur
listes d'attentes ou refusés dans toutes
les facultés où ils avaient candidaté
parcours su avait pourtant été mise en
place pour permettre un système plus
juste
or dans certaines universités la
sélection passe encore pour une ce pour
une part une forme pardon de tirage au
sort sans doute plus technologique mais
tout aussi injuste
ces dernières incapable de traiter
correctement et individuellement les
dossiers ont mis en place des
algorithmes pour classer et évaluer les
candidats cela en plus de pénaliser des
lycéens méritants conduit à standardiser
le profil des candidats
les conclusions de la cour des comptes
dans son rapport de février 2020 vont
dans le même sens
la cour a en effet souligné le manque de
transparence
l'aspect uniforme des dossiers
l'automatisation croissante du système
elle note également que la motivation
des élèves n'est pas prise en compte et
conclut que les performances de parcours
su ne sont pas meilleures que celles de
l'antique système apb votre gouvernement
avait affiché sa volonté de remettre de
l'humain dans le système de
l'orientation et de l'inscription à
l'université
la réalité est malheureusement tout
autre madame la ministre
qu'envisagez-vous de faire pour remédier
à cette situation d' injustice criante
la parole le cannabis de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche et
l'innovation
alain vidal vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
sénatrice mais c'est les sénateurs mais
la sénatrice dommage parce qu'une partie
de votre question décrit en fait
l'ancien système
je ne peux pas vous laisser dire au
regard du travail qui menait dans
l'ensemble des établissements du
secondaire pour accompagner orienter les
lycéens ce qui ne se faisait pas à
l'époque d'apb à l'égard du travail qui
est mené dans l'ensemble des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
pour regarder les dossiers pour faire
des propositions
ce qui n'existait pas autant d'un bébé
que le système que nous avons mis en
place est un système inhumain et un
système fondé sur des algorithmes ce
serait mépriser l'ensemble du travail
mené par les professeurs aussi bien dans
le secondaire que dans le supérieur
alors madame la sénatrice
cette année c'est 2% de voeux
supplémentaires qui ont été exprimées
par les lycéens malgré la période de
confinement c'est un accompagnement
exceptionnel malgré la période de
confinement c'est à l'heure où nous
parlons plus de huit lycéens sur dix qui
ont eu des propositions d'admission qui
correspondait à leur choix c'est une
procédure complémentaire qui va démarrer
le 16 juin plutôt que les années
précédentes pour que là encore nous
puissions mieux accompagner les
candidats avant même l'obtention de leur
baccalauréat
alors oui madame la sénatrice je l' ai
toujours dit ce dispositif a vocation à
s'améliorer en permanence parce que
c'est un dispositif qui est profondément
humain qui est profondément porté par
une communauté universitaire et qui est
profondément plébiscité par les parents
comme par les étudiants mais il ya
encore parfois des difficultés et bien
sûr nous travaillons à les résoudre
chaque jour j'en veux pour exemple le
fait que nous ayons 20 % de boursiers en
plus j'en veux pour exemple que la
procédure est permis de créer plus de
900 places dans les iut
deux régions de région parisienne et
notamment aussi en seine et marne
j'en veux pour preuve que grâce au
rapport du sénateur la faune le fait que
l'île de france soit maintenant
considérée comme une académie et permis
une meilleure mobilité sociale
donc oui madame la sénatrice nous
progressons nous améliorons chaque année
et nous sommes très fiers de ce
dispositif
merci la parole est à notre collègue
jean-marie janssen pour le groupe de
l'union centriste j'avais la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues sénateurs
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le ministre avait annoncé hier
un plan de relance pour l'aéronautique à
hauteur de 15 milliards d'euros
du point de vue financier cette annonce
répond à très forte inquiétude d'un
secteur particulièrement touché par la
crise sanitaire et ses conséquences
économiques
je tiens à saluer la réactivité du
gouvernement sur ce sujet capital
cette enveloppe est conséquente c'est
vrai mais elle doit surtout être
efficace pour persévérer l'autre toi
l'emploi dans notre territoire
vendredi dernier l'entreprise daher
spécialisé dans l'équipement
aéronautique annoncé un plan de
restructuration concernant ces deux
sites de montrichard et saint julien de
ceux dont dans mon département de loir
et cher avec une basse avec une baisse
de 43% de son chiffre d'affaires depuis
le début de l'année l'entreprise connaît
de graves difficultés qui menacent
fortement les 800 emplois locaux de
daher en loir-et-cher soutenir et
relancer la filière aéronautique
commence par sécuriser les
investissements industriels du secteur
et l'emploi local
ceci pour toutes les entreprises du
secteur aéronautique
depuis les équipementiers jusqu aux
compagnies aériennes
il est essentiel de donner à des
entreprises comme des airs de la
visibilité et des éléments concrets de
soutien pour les aider à prendre les
bonnes décisions à faire les bons choix
stratégiques et à ne pas s'engager
j'ai dans une restructuration trop
lourde sur le plan de l'emploi ainsi
pouvez vous nous détailler les modalités
de ce plan de relance et nous garantir
que la priorité sera la préservation de
l'emploi pour dr
comme pour les entreprises du secteur
aéronautique
merci quand vous répondre la parole et
où madame la secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur jean sense vous
l'avez vous avez raison la filière
aéronautique c'est 300000 emplois pas
seulement ces grandes entreprises que
nous connaissons tous
airbus safran thales mais c'est
également 1200 entreprises qui
constituent le tissu de la
sous-traitance et qui permet à la france
d'être le seul pays avec les états unis
à pouvoir construire un avion de a à z
cette filière aéronautique est un
fleuron de notre industrie nous devons
la protéger pas la protéger en empêchant
des restructurations nécessaires dans un
marché qui a disparu vous savez comme
moi que les carnets de commande sont
aujourd'hui à zéro dans un contexte où
l'aviation commerciale est cloué au sol
mais accompagné cette industrie pour que
demain face à la compo la concurrence
américaine et la concurrence chinoise
elles soient au rendez-vous et puisse
rebondir non seulement en gardant sa
position de leader mais aussi en
inventant les motorisations nouvelles
celles qui seront beaucoup plus économe
en carbone beaucoup moins émettrices et
c'est tout le pari technologique que
nous faisons avec laon puis l'appui de
l'ensemble du gouvernement
et pour revenir sur ce plan c'est
effectivement un plan d'envergure
inédite inédite par son ampleur 15
milliards d'euros mais inédite par son
contenu car il rassemble différents
instruments qui doit nous permettre
d'assurer cette transformation
une charte donneur d'ordre sous traitant
qui justement a sur la solidarité dans
la filière et cette visibilité que nous
appelons tous de nous veut un fonds de
consolidation qui va associer les quatre
grands groupes et qui va permettre à des
pme et des nti d'atteindre une taille
critique killer
remettra de traverser la crise des
commandes publiques et je veux remercier
ici
la ministre des forces armées qui a
contribué fortement à accompagner ce
plan en apportant aussi de la visibilité
sur les commandes dual les commandes
militaires également pour les forces de
l'ordre à hauteur de 800 millions
d'euros
mon avance la programmation a qui était
initialement prévu
enfin des investissements dans la r&d à
hauteur de 1,5 milliard d'euros qui nous
permettra de protéger les compétences et
de répondre à cet enjeu majeur
justement de protéger l'emploi pas pour
ne pas être compétitif mais au contraire
pour être au rendez vous des défis de
demain je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant leurs
collègues jacques grosperrin pour le
groupe l'est républicain vous avez la
parole
merci président mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale à
laquelle j'associe stéphane pieds noirs
dont les tribunes avec bien un grand
nombre de sénateurs
monsieur le ministre dans le cadre de la
reprise progressive des cours à l'école
votre dispositif sport santé et culture
civisme deux aces de ces entend offrir
des activités éducatives sur le temps
scolaire
ce dispositif se veut une réponse à la
crise sanitaire et au contrôle et
contraintes du protocole qui entraîne
des conséquences très lourdes sur le
nombre d'élèves prise en charge
nous savons tous que l'absence de
reprise scolaire pour une part non
négligeable et constater et regretter
par tous car les dangers de la
déscolarisation physiques sont immenses
les dégâts seraient irréversibles si la
majorité des enfants ne retrouvait pas
le chemin de l'école avant septembre
prochain
hier encore le maire de besançon me
demander d'intercéder auprès de vous
pour un desserrement du protocole sur ce
col sanitaire dans la mesure où les
parcs sont ouverts les écoles a
aujourd'hui ne le sont pas totalement
cependant monsieur le ministre ce
dispositif deux aces de ses douze
interroge car l'ouverture de l'école aux
intervenants extérieurs pendant le temps
scolaire doit rester une exception mais
surtout ce dispositif nous inquiète car
de nombreux maires nous appelle tous les
jours pour nous faire part de leurs
difficultés matérielles humaines et
surtout financière ces nouvelles charges
sont une fois de plus assumée par les
collectivités locales
et ce ne sont pas les 110 euros par jour
par groupes d'élèves de 15 qui seront
suffisants nous sommes dans le temps
scolaire et c'est à l'état d'assumer ses
charges nous sénateurs as enceinte où
est l ancien président qui précédait
donc le président larcher jules ferry
nous ne voulons pas supprimer la
position égalité égalité de la divise
républicaine qui se trouve au fronton de
nos écoles
depuis la loi du 14 juillet 1881 liberté
égalité fraternité
car je sais que c'est dispositif
insuffisamment financé sera surtout en
zone rurale et parfois en zone urbaine
source d'inégalité la sollicitation des
finances locales ne serait devenir le
moyen ordinaire de mise en oeuvre
budgétaire de votre gouvernement les
collectivités locales vont payer très
lourdement déjà les conséquences de la
crise une question et une seule monsieur
le ministre
quelles sont vos intentions sur la
pérennité et le financement futur des
deux s ii c merci et bénéficier des
secondes jules ferry pour vous répondre
la parole est aux ministres de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le président je découvre
que votre longévité est encore plus
grande que ce que je croyais et grâce
aux sénateurs regroupés sur le sénateur
européen
merci pour pour cette question qui est
extrêmement importante dans un contexte
qui est très particulier il ya plusieurs
points d'accord entre ce que vous avez
pu dire est ce que je pourrais vous
répondre d'abord l'importance du sport
et de la culture ne perdons pas le sens
de cette mesure si nous avons élaboré ce
dispositif deux aces de cesser pour
promouvoir quelque chose qui je crois
fait consensus dans notre société c'est
à dire plus d'activité sportive plus
d'activités culturelles
plus d'éducation à la santé et au
civisme aussi dans notre pays et donc
c'est l'occasion d'avancer sur cette
question je rappelle que le dispositif
n'a rien d'obligatoire donc ce n'est en
rien une contrainte les les communes
peuvent y adhérer si elles le veulent et
d'ailleurs plus de 1000 communes l'ont
fait en france y compris je crois aux
neuf dans votre beau département du
doubs donc il ya réellement une
positivité de contractualisation entre
l'état et les communes et je crois que
c'est ce type de relation que justement
les communes appelle souvent de leurs
voeux
on dit parfois 110 euros vous l'avez dit
par jour et par élève ça n'est pas assez
je rappelle que c'est un forfait
autrement dit même trois heures
correspondent à ses 110 euros pour pour
15 élèves par ailleurs l'éducation
nationale participent des professeurs
peuvent peuvent participer donc il ya
toute une série de cas de figure où en
réalité ça peut ne rien coûter à la
commune cela ne doit pas nous faire
perdre de vue les objectifs de fond qui
sont d'arriver à ce que nous ayons une
vision complète du temps de l'enfant au
moins du lundi au vendredi si ce n'est
davantage entre le temps scolaire et le
temps périscolaire et oui je crois qu'il
est bon qu'il n'y ait pas de cloison
étanche entre les deux c'est évidemment
de temps différents mais il doit y avoir
une articulation quand un enfant fait de
la musique le mercredi c'est évidemment
bon pour ses apprentissages le reste de
la semaine donc l'alliance collectivités
locales l'éducation nationale n'était en
rien une remise en cause du caractère
national du service public nous y sommes
tous très attachés
mais c'est au contraire signes de
coopération et bien entendu nous devons
dans le futur progresser encore en
matière d'activités sportives et
culturelles
enfin je serai sur la même longueur
d'onde que vous sur l'allégement du
protocole sanitaire
nous y travaillons avec le premier
ministre nous avons un conseil de
défense vendredi pour aller dans ce sens
rappelons que nous avons voulu à tout
prix ce déconfinement scolaire qu'il a
fallu le courage du président de la
république pour le décidé le 11 mai
aujourd'hui tout le monde voit que
c'était la bonne décision et d'une
certaine façon c'est un hommage que vous
nous rendez en nous demandant
d'accélérer
merci merci monsieur 2010 pour la
précision historique
jules ferry n'a été que trois semaines
président du sénat vous voyez que je
joue les prolongations
voilà la parole est maintenant notre
collègue maryse carrère pour le groupe
du rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre en
charge des transports et j'associe tous
mes collègues du groupe rds aux
sénateurs de territoires ruraux
monsieur le ministre 7 heures pour
relier aurillac à paris 5h30 pour tarbes
paris nous mesurons aujourd'hui la
réalité de l'enclavement de nos
territoires dont la seule porte de
sortie reste l'avion pour lutter contre
cet éloignement de nombreuses
collectivités n'ont eu d'autre choix que
d'investir massivement dans des lignes a
obligation de service public afin de
garder leur territoire attractif pour
les hautes-pyrénées cela représente 2
millions d'euros par an ma collègue
josiane cost vous a déjà interpellé sur
ses craintes et il y a quelques semaines
et celle ci semble se confirmer en effet
dans un communiqué récent air france et
sa filiale europe ont annoncé vouloir
réduire de près de 40% leurs vols
régionaux d'ici 2021
une telle décision vienne une nouvelle
fois touché de plein fouet des
territoires déjà durement éprouvé vous
l'aurez compris nous ne pouvons accepter
des décisions unità unilatérale venant
pénaliser de nombreux bassins
économiques et industriels aujourd'hui
la dg assez nous indique que ces lignes
auront l'obligation de respecter de
nouveau les esp sous peine de pénalités
à partir du 1er juillet ajoutant
toutefois qu'il faudra tenir compte de
la soutenabilité financière de ces
lignes en laissant à chaque collectivité
le soin de négocier avec l'opérateur
aussi monsieur le ministre alors que
l'état s'apprête à mettre 7 milliards
d'euros pour sauver le soldat air france
auquel on pourra ajouter 15 milliards
d'euros pour l'aéronautique
un effort considérable quelles
contreparties
allez vous exigez de sept opérateurs
monopolistiques les aux aspects seront
elles bien identifié comme un enjeu
stratégique et essentielle au
développement des territoires
comment comptez vous mesurer les niveaux
de soutenabilité acceptables pourrait
ouvrir ses lignes
en fait mme laisserez-vous les
collectivités seules pour négocier pour
négocier avec air france
toujours plus prompts à alimenter des
procès en non rentabilité au mépris du
service qu'ils rendent au territoire
sans afficher clairement les exigences
de l'état l'état reste le garant de
l'aménagement et l'égalité des
territoires pour les hautes-pyrénées le
cantal où la lozère le seul salut presse
l'avion car nous savons tous
pertinemment que nos territoires
enclavés et éloignées ne bénéficierons
jamais de lignes tgv
merci de secrétaire d'état en charge des
transports
il a deux minutes merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice
merci pour cette question qui me permet
de revenir sur la reprise progressive
des lignes d'aménagement du territoire
linky vous l'avez dit son confit lancé
par l'état et les collectivités
territoriales dont là le but de
connecter les pôles enclavé au reste du
territoire pour ainsi conforter dans
votre activité sur le territoire
métropolitain cela concerne
lignes opérées par air france et ses
filiales en tout cas pour quatre d'entre
elles durant le confinement vous l'avez
dit les restrictions prises par l'état
aux conduits ces lignes à être suspendu
et la reprise progressive s'opère depuis
le 2 juin dernier étant entendu que la
réouverture d'orly devrait encore
accélérer ce processus mais que en tout
état de cause un retour à la normale en
termes de trafic n'est pas anticipé
avant le deuxième semestre 2021 nous
avons évidemment une attention
particulière pour les lignes sous ios
paix j'ai demandé aux opérateurs de se
concerter en détail avec les
collectivités de manière à définir un
programme de vols adaptés à la demande
demande qui pour l'instant reste assez
modeste en vue en vue de la reprise est
donc en fonction de la demande
actuellement anticipé les services du
ministère sont par ailleurs à l'ecoute
comme ce fut le cas en début de semaine
pour l'aéroport de lourdes tarbes ce
plan concerté devra être communiquée
avant le 1er juillet dans lequel que
vous avez d'ailleurs rappelé et je
partage avec vous la conviction madame
la sénatrice que ces lignes sont
importantes pour la vitalité des
territoires et que ces dessertes doivent
en conséquence être préservé merci la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
hervé gillé pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain vous avez la parole pour 2
min
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre madame la ministre mes
chers collègues au nom du groupe
socialiste et républicain je souhaite
vous interpeller sur le plan de soutien
collectivités locales et territoriales
présenté ce matin en conseil des
ministres la relance du pays ne se fera
qu'avec un soutien ambitieux des
collectivités face à la crise les élus
locaux ont assumé un rôle essentiel pour
pallier les manques et assurer la
continuité de l'état soutenir leur
trésorerie et compenser en partie leurs
pertes ne suffiront pas il faut leur
donner une capacité d'agir
une force de frappe et ce n'est pas
l'ambition de votre plan 4,5 milliards
d'euros alors que la baisse des recettes
est estimé à 7 5 milliards par le
président 15,9 que nous avons auditionné
récemment avec le président bocage
les chiffres parlent certaines
estimations portent même sur plus de 10
milliards d'euros
les départements en première ligne pour
la solidarité accumule les pertes et ne
bénéficierait que d'une avance sur les
droits de mutation
l'effet ciseau budgétaire va être
redoutable les régions sont quasiment
oublié alors qu'elle pourrait impulser
des actions de relance économique et de
soutien aux entreprises dans les bassins
d'emploi la dotation de soutien à
l'investissement local et doté d'un
milliard supplémentaire
envisagez-vous l'élargissement des
bénéficiaires en rendant éligible au
delà des posters les pôles territoriaux
les syndicats de pays et les parcs
naturels régionaux une crise sociale
s'annonce sans précédent ne la
sous-estimer pas de nouvelles dépenses
de solidarité s'impose explosion du
nombre de bénéficiaires du rsa est déjà
un million de nouveaux demandeurs
d'emploi ccsc yes département sont
fortement impactées tous les territoires
sont concernés madame la ministre
ce plan de soutien n'est qu'une
compensation les collectivités peuvent
être un vecteur puissant de la relance
quels véritables moyens allez vous
mettre leur disposition pour la parole
automobilistes à la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités banal
ministre merci monsieur le sénateur de
me poser cette question qui me permet de
préciser les questions précédentes où
les réponses que j'ai fait aux questions
précédentes
d'abord vous menez d'accord sur le rôle
des collectivités territoriales et
peut-être rappeler que le plfr 3 est un
plan d'urgence qui répond à une
situation d'urgence
pour les collectivités territoriales par
exemple en ce qui concerne les communes
les intercommunalités
bien évidemment nous savons qu'un
certain nombre de communes par exemple
des communes touristiques ou des
communes d'outre-mer
voyez jusqu'à 30 ou 35 % de leurs
recettes réelles de fonctionnement
touchés donc c'est un plan d'urgence et
nous répondons en urgence avec cette
garantie de recettes pour les communes
les intercommunalités et je pressais
aussi les syndicats de transport puisque
naturellement nous savons que le vtt ou
le vn comme on dit maintenant et bien a
énormément baissé
donc c'est une mesure d'urgence et nous
répondons à la mesure de cette urgence
je précise monsieur le sénateur que
jamais un gouvernement n'a accordé aux
mères une garantie aussi complète et
aussi sécurisante
on peut remonter dans le temps sur
d'autres crises ça n'a jamais été fait
par ailleurs la décision j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure que le premier ministre
annonce et un million supplémentaire de
des cil 1 milliard pardon excusez moi je
voulais vous dire que ces crédits seront
mobilisés en priorité sur la transition
écologique je n'ai pas le temps de le
dire tout à l'heure mais c'est très
important de le préciser
par ailleurs en ce qui concerne les
régions de france
nous avons engagé un dialogue avec
chacune d'entre elles dans la
perspective d'un accord de partenariat
au début de l'été sur leurs recettes et
leurs investissements
je dirais d'elle même et de l'état dans
le cadre des futurs contrats de plan
état région qui sont en renouvellement
club et je termine pour vous dire que je
n'oublie pas l'outre-mer puisque nous
avons déjà versé 60 millions aux régions
d'outre-mer en lien avec la recette
particulière de l'octroi de mer qui a
beaucoup baissé
donc nous l'avons mis aussi dans le plfr
3 monsieur gilles et quelques secondes
merci vous parlez de mesures d'urgence
mais je pense que la relance économique
écologique et social se doit de
mobiliser des leviers puissants ils ne
sont pas au rendez vous et je pense que
dans ce cas là les les attentes et les
espoirs vont être déçus merci la parole
est maintenant à dominique de legge dont
le groupe b république à la 2 minutes
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues le 2 mai 2018 la
commission européenne publié un projet
de cadre financier pluriannuel de 11
milliards 4 d'euros pour alimenter un
fonds hors pair de défense le 27 mai
dernier la commission dans le cadre du
plan de relance propose de ramener la
dotation de gu milliards c'est-à-dire
moins 30%
madame la ministre le président macron
un fait du renforcement de l'autonomie
stratégique de l'europe en particulier
au niveau militaire l'un des marqueurs
de son quinquennat
ainsi que la boussole de son action
européenne le déploiement d'un fonds
européen défense ambitieux devrait en
être la concrétisation est le symbole
comment devons nous interpréter ces
revirements et quelles en sont les
conséquences pratiques et
opérationnelles notamment pour
l'industrie de la défense dans le cadre
du plan de relance pour vous répondre
par an le cas madame la milice des
armées merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je voudrais d'abord
rappeler ce que chacun sait ici c'est
qu'il ya encore peu de temps
imaginez que l'europe puisse investir un
euro dans le domaine de la défense et
est inenvisageable
par conséquent la création d'un fonds
européen de défense c'est un changement
complet de paradigme et c'est une
révolution pour la première fois en
effet des fonds européens seront
consacrés au développement d'une base
industrielle et technologique de défense
européenne alors vous avez raison de
rappeler l'historique la commission a re
européenne avait proposé il ya quelques
mois d'investir 13 milliards d'euros sur
la période de dix noeuds 2021 et 2027
la présidente finlandaise avait peu
avant la le début de la crise du coc vie
de ramener à 6 milliards et demi c'est à
dire moitié moins cette somme avec un
certain nombre de partenaires européens
nous sommes remontés à la charge
nous sommes aujourd'hui mobilisée pour
obtenir plus nous sommes à 9 milliards
d'euros
ce n'est pas suffisant c'est un progrès
mais je vous la corde le compte n'y est
pas encore
et comme nous n'avons pas dit notre
dernier mot nous avons écrit aux hauts
représentants de l'union européenne
ainsi qu'à nos homologues européens afin
que le fonds européen de défense puisse
être porté à un niveau ambitieux et nous
en avons aujourd'hui besoin plus que
jamais parce que la crise du coc vide
nous a montré que nous avions besoin de
plus d'europe et de plus de souveraineté
européenne le fonds européen défense
devra donc prendre aussi sa part à la
relance économique dont nous avons tous
collectivement besoin au sein de
l'espace européen
et hier avec la ministre de la
transition écologique et le ministre de
l'économie et des finances nous avons
fait des annonces pour soutenir le
secteur aéronautique et j'ai annoncé 600
millions d'euros de commandes par
anticipation afin de venir en soutien de
cette filière aéronautique et vous
pouvez compter sur une chose c'est que
je continuerai de me battre pour
soutenir la base industrielle et
technologique de défense non seulement
française mais européenne
monsieur de lège
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président merci madame
la ministre merci de cette réponse mais
permettez moi de vous dire que j'ai
vraiment l'impression que cette affaire
est assez emblématique de ce que
j'appellerais la méthode macron on fait
une analyse et un constat juste nous
avons besoin d'une coopération
européenne au niveau de la défense fasse
le premier temps puis le deuxième temps
on se lance dans des déclarations
totalement irresponsable isolé et de
façon un peu provocatrice
je veux bien évidemment les déclarations
qui ont été faites autour de l'alliance
atlantique
vous savez aussi bien que moi que nos
partenaires européens considèrent que
cette alliance est indispensable à leur
sécurité est donc le résultat
eh bien c'est exactement la verse de ce
que nous voulions savoir que comme nous
n'avons pas réussi à convaincre que nous
étions tous seuls comme nous étions les
meilleurs
et bien aujourd'hui nos partenaires
européens ont dû mal entendre la voix de
la france hier nous suivre je compte sur
vous pour améliorer les choses
merci chers collègues nous avons été 110
aujourd'hui tout en respectant les
règles fixées collectivement sur
l'autorité les questeurs et saluer mes
collègues qui acceptent ainsi d'être
dans les tribunes
je vous rappelle que deux prochaines
questions d'actualité auront lieu le 17
juin
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres merci
la séance est suspendue et reprendra à
16h35 pour la lecture des conclusions la
commission mixte paritaire sur le projet
de loi relatifs à diverses dispositions
dit à la crise sanitaire ainsi qu'au
retrait du royaume uni de l'union
européenne la séance est suspendue elle
sera reprise à 16h35 merci
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur public sénat c'est l'un
des sujets qui a été plusieurs fois
abordé lors de cette séance est bien le
sort des lignes aériennes d'aménagement
du territoire on va en parler avec jean
baptiste djebbari bonjour c'est qu'un
terminal aux transports ces lignes qui
desservent des territoires des
territoires aujourd'hui qui sinon serait
délaissée sont elles en danger
aujourd'hui avec la crise
vous vous êtes dit vigilant vigilant
mais encore vigilant d'abord pour
accompagner la reprise vous savez que la
reprise progressive du trafic intérieur
s'opère depuis le 2 juin dernier depuis
que la règle et 100 km a été levée et il
faut à la fois être lucide sur la
demande
la fréquentation le nombre de voyageurs
qui aujourd'hui montrent dans ces avions
qui reste très modeste de l'ordre de 20
à 25% et donc l'objectif c'est bien de
mettre pour 7
ce redémarrage progressif le bon nombre
d'avions la bonne la bonne offre
en face de la demande et c'est ce que
nous allons faire en lien avec les élus
or la période de la réserve électorale
complique un peu ces échanges parfois
mais j'ai demandé notamment aux grands
opérateurs à air france d'avoir ses
dialogues avec les 46 élus les lignes
question indispensable à l'aménagement
du territoire
elles vont être préservés laborde de
choses je dis que ces lignes était vital
pour l'aménagement du territoire et je
suis élu de limoges comme vous savez
nous avons des lignes sur un petit
service public
leur objectif n'est pas la rentabilité
mais bien de préserver l'attractivité de
ces territoires des lignes ou bien
souvent comme à aurillac le voyage par
le train en pas la route n'est pas une
une solution satisfaisante notamment
pour le tissu de pme et d'entreprises
locales donc il faut préserver
il faut préserver ses dunes
d'aménagement du territoire il faut
accompagner la reprise
avec clairvoyance avec lucidité parce
qu'aujourd'hui et vous le savez la
demande est relativement modeste
nous avons le mois d'août qui
traditionnellement est un mois peu
utilisé par les voyageurs et il faudra
pour septembre est particulièrement près
moi j'ai demandé à ce que l'ensemble des
opérateurs au lien avec les élus
produisent un plan avant le 1er juillet
de manière à ce que ce plan soit
exécutée au cours de l'été et après et
surtout cela s'inscrit bien sûr dans le
contexte d'une crise pour l'aéronautique
absolument sans précédent
hier
le gouvernement a annoncé un plan de
soutien de 15 milliards d'euros axé
notamment sur la reconversion verte est
ce vraiment la réalité n'est ce pas une
nouvelle fois une perfusion pour un
secteur dont on sait qu'il va attendre
plusieurs années avant le retour à la
normale non d'abord c'est un plan de un
plan de résistance est un plan de
conquête un peu de résistance pour
amortir la crise
vous en connaissez les effets qui est
déjà terrible 95 % des vols qui ont été
supprimés alors ça reprend
progressivement une industrie qui pâtit
beaucoup de la crise le chiffre des abus
sont connus environ 40% de baisse
d'activité pendant deux ans donc une
crise durable qu'un plan de résistance
ça c'est l'ensemble des mesures que vous
connaissez parfaitement bien l'activité
partielle les prêts garantis par l'état
les fonds de consolidation et puis un
plan de conquête parce que le vrai enjeu
du transport aérien comme du reste
l'ensemble des transports et le
verdissement de deux façons de voir les
choses pour un secteur aussi polluant
oui enfin qui est beaucoup moins
polluant que qu'on le dise et 2,5 pour
cent des gaz et les missions des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre mais
ça reste effectivement un des grands
enjeux et donc il ya deux façons de voir
les choses soient effectivement vous
faites un peu comme en 2008 concurrence
avec de vieux avions pour finalement
volé pour pas cher comme l'avait fait à
l'époque les américains pour
reconstituer les marges
soit vous investissez massivement ce que
nous faisons le choix politique que nous
faisons nous investissons massivement
avec un horizon assez clair un premier
avion régional hybride en 2027 et le
successeur vert de l'a320 en 2035
c'est un défi considérable mais ce n'est
pas tout à fait hors de portée une
dernière question sur le projet de loi
qui a été présenté ce matin au conseil
des ministres sur les quatre mois qui
vont suivre
le 10 juillet est ce que c'est bien un
état d'urgence bis et notamment pour les
transports non pas un état d'urgence bis
vous avez que depuis le 2 juin nous
avons assoupli un certain nombre de
règles notamment le respect strict de la
règle du 1 m dans les rames donc les
choses se font par contre nous gardons
dans le droit commun pour que les quatre
prochains mois à compter du 10 juillet
la possibilité de poser à nouveau des
régulations si besoin s'en faisait
sentir
c'est notamment la situation sanitaire a
été amenée été à nouveau ce que nous ne
souhaitons pas évidemment mais il était
sage de se préserver de se garder cette
possibilité dans la loi
et bien merci beaucoup aux gens vers
ribéry d'avoir répondu à mes questions
autres thématiques bien sûr qui a marqué
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement la question des
manifestations actuellement les
manifestations anti
raciste et la question si des violences
policières jo propose tout de suite
d'écoutés edouard philippe tout à
l'heure qui s'est exprimé et qui a parlé
lui plutôt des violences à l'égard de la
police dans sa réponse écoutez je ne
laisserai jamais dire que la police ou
la gendarmerie serait d organisation des
institutions violentes ou raciste elles
ne sont je le dis madame la présidente
ni l'une ni l'autre la police et la
gendarmerie ou plus exactement les
policiers et les gendarmes exerce des
missions redoutablement difficile vous
le savez vous avez évoqué cette période
particulière et au fond malheureuse dit
des gilet jaune
cette période a été violente elle n'a
pas été le fait de violences choisi
exercée par la police sur des
manifestants pacifiques
je vous le dis comme je le pense comme
je les ai vécus madame la présidente
mais nous avons insisté dans cette
période à des mises en cause à des
insultes à des crachats à des violences
incroyablement intense à l'égard des
policiers et des gendarmes
voilà pour la réponse tout à leur dédain
philippe je suis avec le président du
groupe l air au sénat bruno retailleau
vous avez questionné le premier ministre
vous aussi sur ce sujet ce que vous êtes
satisfait du fait que le premier
ministre a plutôt lancé dans une défense
défense de l'or parce que c'est pour
vous suffisant dans le contexte actuel
bah écoute elle est venue au sénat
évidemment pour désavouer féministe
parce qu'on a le sentiment
ces derniers jours et les policiers les
gendarmes ont eu le sentiment qu'ils
étaient totalement lâché il m'a d'abord
dit je suis le premier défenseur des
flics de fouet mais après après avoir
plongé nos gendarmes et nos policiers
dans cette situation ou en parlant
justement de soupes sont avérés ce
serait pour eux une sorte de présomption
de culpabilité
il a parlé sauf castaner je vous
rappelle que l émotion devait être
supérieur au droit à la loi à la règle
d'or avant des manifestations c'est
inédit
ça veut dire que l'émotion peut supposer
peut justifier qu'on enfreignent la
règle de droit
non moi ce que je veux dire que je redis
encore manifesté aujourd'hui donc ces
manifestations de
avoir lieu bien sûr ce que je veux dire
simplement c'est qu'il ya deux poids
deux mesures et des français qui sont
condamnés qui ont payé des amendes de
135 euros parce que lorsqu'il allait
prendre baguette ils n'avaient pas leurs
attestations il ya quelques semaines sur
tout ce que je veux dire c'est que nos
forces de l'ordre c'est le bouclier de
la république
elles ont été en première ligne contre
le terrorisme elles ont été au premier
league contre les violences de rue au
quotidien elles sont en premier souvent
caillasser insulter parfois blessés et
aujourd'hui nous avons voulu soutenir
l'honneur de nos gendarmes l'honneur de
nos policiers parce que leur honneur
c'est l'honneur de la république c'est
l'honneur de la france mais y at-il un
problème de racisme dans les forces de
l'ordre et plus largement dans la
société française emmanuel macron ce
matin à parler en conseil des ministres
du racisme comme d'une maladie qui
touche toute la société
mais je me bats contre cette
généralisation le seul fait que vous me
posiez cette question
vous voyez bien que les approximations
monsieur castaner ont fonctionné il a
laissé croire aux journalistes aux
français qui pouvait y avoir une police
une gendarmerie qui était en réalité
coupable de racisme
or c'est faux les cas individuels qui
peuvent exister doivent être durement
sanctionné mais moi je me bats parce
qu'on voit bien qu'ils aient des gens
qui voudraient a signé les français à
leur couleur de peau qui voudraient
communautariser en réalité la france et
qui voudraient désigné la france comme
coupable pour la fragiliser pour la
fragmenter et ça ça n'est pas
supportable donc j'attends dans la
prochaine expression du président de
république qu'il soit d'abord ferme
qu'il rappelle des règles de fermeté non
l'émotion ne doit pas dépasser les
règles de droit et surtout l'unité
l'unité française le modèle républicain
qui fait qu'il n'ya pas de communauté au
pluriel qu'il n'y a qu'une seule
communauté la communauté des citoyens
français quelle que soit leur couleur de
peau
il va prendre la parole ce week-end les
présents de la république pour près de
la sortie de crise c'est ce que vous
attendez de lui cette prise de parole
sur ce sujet oui bien sûr mais elle est
trop tardive elle est trop tarifs parce
que pendant des jours et des jours on a
vu ses ministres notamment la garde des
sceaux qui reçoit
qui veut s'introduire finalement dans
une affaire qui est toujours en cours ça
c'est un affaiblissement de l'état de
droit qui on a vu encore une fois les
déclarations d'un ministre
bien sûr de de l'intérieur des
déclarations justement qui ont jeté
l'opprobre sur nos gendarmes et nos
policiers il ya merci beaucoup à bruno
retailleau d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
et enfin j'ai plaisir à d'accueillir
patrick kanner le président du groupe ps
au sénat
on va parler nous aussi bien de ce même
sujet des manifestations ce sujet des
violences
tout d'abord vous étiez présent lors de
ces manifestations anti raciste hier des
manifestations qui ne sont pourtant pas
autorisé bruno retailleau disais à
l'instant ces manifestations elles n'ont
pas le droit d'avoir lieu qu'est ce que
vous répondez à cela bien sûr il ya la
règle et puis il peut être des
exceptions
je pense que le gouvernement a eu raison
de considérer que regarde la situation
ne fallait pas rajouter de la crise à la
crise et la manifestation s'est très
bien passé dans le calme avec des
masques pour les uns et pour les autres
donc je pense qu' il fallait que cette
expression puisse se faire dans de
bonnes conditions et c'était le cas hier
soir sur la place de la république et le
gouvernement qui a présenté cette
semaine des mesures sur la déontologie
dans la police il a raison c'est une
bonne réaction de la part du
gouvernement
on a entendu aussi aujourd'hui beaucoup
de défenses des forces de l'ordre dans
la voix d'edouard philippe je considère
que nous avons trois cent mille
policiers et gendarmes dans notre pays
bien évidemment il n'y a pas de racisme
d'état ce serait une aberration que de
que de l'affirmer
par contre nous devons avoir une
tolérance zéro je reprends l'expression
du premier ministre sur le fait qu'il y
a malheureusement des phénomènes
racistes dans ce corps les tarnais
tolérance sur ces phénomènes et qu'il y
a qu il y a eu sûrement peut-être un
laisser-aller qu'il faut absolument
corriger
comment se fait-il que des serviteurs de
la république puisse défendre
de fait à titre privé ou public des
valeurs qui sont contraires la
république donc posons le diagnostic
regardons les remèdes et mettons les en
oeuvre hélas le parlement est à sa place
pour le dire à l'exécutif
vous parlez des rapports entre le
parlement et l'exécutif que pensez vous
du fait que le gouvernement crée sa
propre commission pour enquêter sur sa
gestion du coc vide
ce sont des bonnes pratiques c'est un
retour d'expérience clame l'exil
écoutez quand on a deux commissions d
enquête qui sont vont se réunir
l'assemblée au sénat
on ne s'amuse pas permis comme
l'expression à créer sa propre
commission denquête de fait c'est tout à
fait dommageable je crois que ça nahman
rats a rien de plus
faisons confiance là aussi aux
parlementaires députés et sénateurs pour
faire toute la lumière sur cette crise
et donc le gouvernement pouvait
totalement s'appuyer sur notre
savoir-faire notre gouvernement
lorsqu'il propose cette enquête de son
côté qu'est ce que cela veut dire
son enquête j'ai parlé de mépris à
l'égard du du parlement ça peut être
aussi un acte de défiance du
gouvernement à l'égard du parlement
alors que le parlement a été tout à fait
à la hauteur depuis le début de cette
crise et donc c'est tout à fait dommage
tant dans le même temps gérard larcher
est appelé à contribuer à la sortie de
crise donc emmanuel macron demande est
bien au président du parlement et bien
de participer à tout cela c'est un signe
de confiance de sa part
écoutez c'est bien consulté le président
larcher où le président ferrand
naturellement mais si c'est pour créer
de la confusion institutionnelle ou de
la confusion politique a créé pour vous
une confusion institutionnelle parce que
quelque part le parlement travaille fait
des propositions fait des propositions
de loi il n'y a aucune raison
aujourd'hui à ce que quelque part nous
devions des collaborateurs du
gouvernement l'exécutif doit fixer son
cap et manifestement ce sera le cas
puisque dimanche prochain le prudence
des trains plus va s'exprimer mais
attendez ce sens que j'espère que la
dimension sociale sera prise en compte
eh bien merci beaucoup patrick anr le
président du groupe socialiste à mon
micro pour se débride des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
c'est la fin de ce débris consacré aux
questions d'actu mais l'actualité
parlementaire elles continuent elles
continuent au sénat et on va prendre la
direction de la salle monory ou olivier
véran le ministre des solidarités et de
la santé s'exprime devant les sénateurs
de la commission des affaires sociales
au coeur de cette audition bien sûr la
gestion de la crise du coc vide 19 mais
aussi le ségur de la santé qui en
découlent tout de suite on prend la
direction de la salle monory merci
monsieur le président je serais moins
long que dix minutes dans mes propos
liminaire parce que comme vous j'aime le
débat